Let's start by revisiting the illustration we used in the threads and
concurrency lecture.
There we explained that threads can be supported at user level, at kernel level,
or both.
Supporting threads at the kernel level means,
that the OS kernel itself is multithreaded.
To do this, the OS kernel maintains some abstraction, for
our threads of data structure to represent threads, and
it performs all of the operations like synchronizations, scheduling,
et cetera, in order to allow these threads to share the physical resources.
Supporting threads at the user level means that there is a user-level library,
that is linked with the application, and
this library provides all of the management in the runtime support for threads.
It will support a data structure that's needed to implement the thread
abstraction and provide all the scheduling synchronization and other mechanisms,
that are needed to make resource management decisions for these threads.
In fact, different processes may use entirely different user-level
libraries that have different ways to
represent threads that support the different scheduling mechanisms, et cetera.
We also discussed several mechanisms,
how user-level threads can be mapped onto the underlying kernel level-threads,
and we said these include a one-to-one, many-to-one, and a many-to-many mapping,
and briefly touched upon some of the pros and cons of each approach.
Now, we'll take a more detailed look at about,
what exactly is needed to describe kernel versus user-level threads, and
to support all of these types of models.